[Music]
hi rob it's mara and kiara we're
roommates from pittsburgh pennsylvania i
recently just finished uh lone star
911 and kira she loves
i love the low files and the outsiders
and the outsiders kara loves the
outsiders now we're watching the low
files so we one are requesting
more seasons of the low files we'd like
it brought back i can contact any on all
of our bass if need be
i think the question really is what's
next for rob lowe is there more seasons
of the low files more firefighter stuff
outsider reboot
what do we say again
thank you for your time rob we love you
we love you rob so much oh you guys you
guys are too too damn cute thank you
i love that you love the low files the
low files is one of my favorite things
um that i've done in terms of the
experience to ride around with my boys
in that tricked-out raptor
chasing
paranormal activity i mean my god it's
basically
two of my favorite shows combined
anthony bourdain parts unknown and
scooby-doo
i mean what could be better
um
and yes you should call a e
100 you should
um i talk to them all the time about
bringing back the low files and i'm
wearing them down the issue was they
never put us where we should be we
should have been next to ancient aliens
which is a massive hit for them and they
put us there once
and we crushed it
but that's where so i think the show's
great i loved it we were gonna
i mean we have all these plans for the
the the next season we were going to go
to hawaii and do the the um the
manahunis and the night marchers
which are really freaky
spirits of hawaii um
loved it so
it's something i would love to do again
um and 911 lone star is is you know this
year even bigger than it was last year
so
um that's going to be going to be around
for a while but um none of it happens
without you guys watching it so fully
appreciate it but yes start the campaign
um for with the folks at e for more low
files thank you thanks for for checking
out